investigators right now trying to figure
out what caused a driver to rear end a
semi that was traveling in these
northbound lanes of the i-15 right now
as you can see the freeway northbound is
still closed and right now a trooper is
blocking the on-ramp coming from gene
and the incident left a trail of debris
scattered across freeway lanes here
according to the nevada highway patrol
two women died after their honda slammed
into the back of a semi truck just
before seven o'clock this morning
the impact took out the back tires of
the truck and sent the car flying off
the road investigators are trying to
determine why that car failed to slow
down before it hit the big rig both were
traveling northbound the driver in the
honda died on the scene her passenger
was rushed to the hospital where she
died authorities say the truck driver
though is ok
this afternoon they're still piecing
together exactly what went wrong
with highway speeds of at least 65 miles
an hour you know speed is always a
factor and you need to be always aware
of your surroundings as well as
what other drivers are doing you need to
make sure you're paying full attention
you know don't be on your cell phone to
be messing with the radio because
anything can happen in that fast of a
second
as far as the traffic impact drivers
heading into town right now are taking
the gene off ramp and continuing
northbound through las vegas boulevard
back out here live
these are live images of the back up the
traffic slowly getting off of i-15 here
at the gene offramp and again the detour
taking drivers off the northbound lanes
through gene and then going up through
las vegas boulevard to get into town
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you